we're here at the German post offices
annual sports festival teams from two
different officers are competing in the
soccer championships the match is being
recorded by an inconspicuous camera
mounted on the sidelines it captures the
action from a variety of angles mixes
the images and sends them directly to
the internet where viewers can stream
the live event former professional
soccer player hands in Muller is amazed
at the technology doctors isn't able to
see this is a revolution for amateur
soccer who doesn't like to see
themselves out on the field this really
is the start of a new era and it's
fascinated the quality is amazing and
it's really easy to use in father
germany's vigor media has been using
conventional technology to film sports
events for decades but these new cameras
cover a hundred and eighty degree field
of vision allowing viewers to watch any
area of the field and zoom in for a
closer look betezh envy until now we've
used much larger and more expensive
technology that required a lot of
technicians this is a very competitive
business so we thought about our focus
for the future we decided to invest in
automated scalable systems that don't
require a lot of personnel to operate
vans earning personal and that's invest
ian Watt and the amateur sports market
seemed just right for the technology
which has been under development for
five years now it's being rolled out in
a big way China's internet birha muth
Alibaba wants to install over a million
wigger systems in Chinese sports fields
across the country
the system will permit paying customers
to create their own customized video
coverage of amateur sports events yeah
Malcolm actors either usually Barba
wants to see fans use their smartphones
to follow sports China is a lot more
advanced when it comes to social media
it has an amazing dynamic much faster
than what we know in Europe but they
don't have the expertise with cameras
and television production that we have
here vas teeny cabinets exactly come
around fancy expertise of using
mid-level bar some sporting events are
probably better than others for the
technology though cycling competitions
for example can only be captured live
when the competitors are standing still
you